so I did my undergrad in front so I'm
originally from I did my masters and my
PhD in the UK I worked at Microsoft in
Beijing which is where I met James lande
then I came to do my postdoc with him in
the U.S Cornell Tech and in Stanford and
then I opened my research lab in Israel
six years ago so I've pretty much lived
everywhere and I've traveled intensely
through South America and Africa so if
you have any questions about
International career at some point I'm
probably a good point to the reference
and I'm happy to tell you about it today
we're going to talk about on body and
out of body experiences as as I was
building that talk I think we're gonna
work more on the out of body experiences
but I can also tell you more about the
rest
so if we think about technology and
technological Evolutions we had
different times in our Evolution where
things change for us as human being and
how we work how we function and so we
have the printing press we have the
steam engine and everything changed we
have this Industrial Revolution and now
people are talking about the fourth
Industrial Revolution some people are
talking about the fifth Industrial
Revolution even though we're not quite
done with the first one yet so we're all
kind of figuring out what does it mean
to live with technology
and if I think about it right now and I
ask you how many out here the phone with
you right now
and whoever is not lifting the hand I
know you're not paying attention to the
talk and whoever has a smart watch with
them right now and a laptop with them
right now and then I can go with any
other types of devices so we're very
much connected
we're all the time connected but
technology is changing and so one of the
main challenge is how do we integrate
very different types of Technologies and
so if we're looking at this image we now
have a robot citizen
what does it mean for us to live in a
world with a robot that is a citizen
it's very different from just having a
phone and an object to work with and so
if we think about machines
how do we imagine coexisting with them
how do I leave with a machine around me
how do I integrate it into my daily life
so I really like this image are they
going to take over
because this is what people are worried
about I mean if you go out of Stanford
in the Bay Area and you tell people that
AI people are freaked out
governments are making decisions because
they're worried about what does it mean
for robots AI to take over decision
making
to take over our human abilities and
these are you know we're laughing about
it because we're working on it we're
developing this technology but people
are worried all over the world these are
Big questions
and so is it humans who have to now
support machines
and that happens all the time whenever
you have a problem and someone goes like
oh I can't the computer won't let me
it's like okay clearly this is an HCI
problem but very much there is this fear
in our society how do we live with
automation
and so we can imagine a better version
and this is the one I want to reassure
you is and that I want to think about is
like I don't quite believe they're gonna
take over
I don't believe this is a future we're
going for but they may coexist with us
and this is something we have to think
about if we think about autonomous cars
we could say okay we divide the lanes
and half of the length of autism scars
and half of the Lander for the other
people
because building a system where
everything is autonomous easy
building a system where half of the car
is autonomous in half are not super
super difficult
and so one way to go is to say okay we
leave half of our world half of our
space to technology and then they can do
their own things
but we give away half of our space I
mean we have to we think do we want to
do this do we want to only have half of
the world for us and half of the world
for machine or do we say okay how do we
build
machines how do we build automation to
work with us to coexist the same way you
have technology with you in your pocket
on your body right now
how do we do this and so this is really
the vision I want you to have in mind
and this is a vision that we're having
in my lab
and so I'm going to give you an example
of drones in firefighting so in Israel
we have a lot of fires I'm not going to
teach you anything California has the
same geography and very very very
similar problems and fires are a major
problem
and so drones are being used right now
to support firefighters into their jobs
but it's not obvious and so we met with
the three top experts in the country
that's the advantage of living in a very
small country so we met with the first
intelligence officer of the Israeli
firefighters the operational r d officer
and the head of drone area of forces
and this is what it looks like so you
have firefighters for example in a
building can be indoor can be outdoor
here we're looking at door you have a
mission commander and very half very
often what they do is they bring a drone
operator
and so when the firefighters need some
help from the Drone to get some
situational awareness about what is
happening they ask the mission Commander
about it who asks the Drone operator who
moves the Drone who gets feedback from
the Drone we then give the feedback to
the mission commander who gives it back
to the firefighters can you see how many
channels can go wrong here
and this is what's happening today we're
not inventing anything and I'm pretty
sure the example of what's happening in
Israel is very similar to a lot of other
places very representative it is hard
it's hard to control a drone it's hard
to control a drone in an environment
with a fire with wind with different
elements happening and on top of it it's
very hard for the firefighters to
actually get this real-time information
and here obviously they need real-time
information if it takes 10 minutes
not worth it probably
they need to know in real time what is
going on
and so our idea was to say could we just
cut down the middleman can the Drone be
part of the team
would that even be an option so the
firefighters walk into a building they
give instruction to the Drone like any
other team member and then they get the
feedback in the same way so we actually
worked with elicitation studies so we
met with some of the firefighters for
those of you who have worked with
firefighters with like emergency
Personnel what's really fun is you start
doing your study they have an alarm and
half of them run away and you have to
wait several hours to finish your study
it's a very different way of doing
research and when you invite 10 students
to come and talk to you but anyway we
still managed to get a lot of
interesting data
what we found and that was very
surprising to us is we did not want to
assume that they would use gesture to
communicate with the Drone because they
have a lot of equipment they have gloves
they have helmets they have a lot of
equipment with them but they're very low
Tech which is also was really weird to
us they're very very low Tech they have
a radio and then that's kind of it and
they're basically going for it and so
they told us they actually wanted to use
gestures because to communicate between
each other they mostly use gestures
but what they do is they use very big
gestures again as a gesture designer
which probably I have done very small
gesture because they already have
equipment and things to carry so I
probably would not want to impose bigger
gestures but because they communicate
with this with each other with those
larger gestures to make sure that they
are seen they wanted the same thing to
communicate with the Drone and so here
those are like examples of four
different gestures and four different
actions that they would need help with
and this is a paper that was published
at a mobile FCI a couple of years ago
so we worked with them we found the
right gestures that they wanted to
implement that fitted with what uh with
the way they work but then the next
question is can we get the Drone to
actually recognize those gestures
because this is not the uh obvious one
and what's interesting here is we work
in a harsh environment
and again there are robots working in
harsh environments today
but when we went down to the literature
there is very very little work on
gesture recognition when there is smoke
or when there is heat Source or very
very little and so we wanted to see we
have this unique challenge of a very
peculiar environment that is very
complex for sensing and for recognition
low visibility some heat points it's not
trivial and so we said okay let's try to
imitate this environment so we use the
same equipment that they are using so we
try to refer to the harsh environment
literature even though it's very sparse
and then we decided to compare existing
sensors so we decided not to build our
own senses like some of you are doing in
your phds but to say okay we have a lot
of sensors that exist can they even
detect
what senses can we use in this condition
so we use three sensors RGB so just a
basic camera basically depth and thermal
camera and then we tried different
algorithms that are well known to try
and see can we actually recognize what's
really interesting here is a depth
camera could not get anything when we
had smoking equipment on
with I mean we knew it wouldn't work
perfectly but we had homes we were like
it is gonna work some no it's not
working and we use like a special indoor
smoke machine that is used to recreate
this type of environments and actually
we could not get anything interesting
out of it
thermal we did not have any heat Source
in our study so we decided to first try
just with the low visibility but without
the heat source already without the heat
Source we had pretty poor resolution so
if you add heat twice then it kind of
game over because then the camera
detects something else and so RGB
actually performed the best
and we do a lot of work with drones
often we use depth cameras because they
are less sensitive to low visibility
environment except when there is smoke
and here we got something more
interesting here using the RGB
so again here The Innovation for our
work was not in designing the best
sensor or designing the best algorithm
but to see what are the sensors and
algorithm that exist that we can use to
actually do this type of research
successfully and we had pretty good
results with like 90 to 98 recognition
90 is not good enough by the way so
sometimes when you're doing uh something
that is not in a harsh environment that
is not with active duty Personnel 90 is
amazing it's like okay worst case people
will try again
when you work with emergency workers 90
is not good enough so yeah sorry wrong
number so it still needs to get better
so there's still more research to be
done but it shows us that there is this
possibility we could actually get
something pretty good here
and so okay and so the next step to for
us was to say okay so now we know yes
oh sorry
missing where it's two cameras and
they're doing the the Gene and the
different options or they actually
no we're using like a dual cameras on
this yes
and so the other thing is now when we
work with trained Personnel you work
with people who know what is a drone
they know how it works they may know the
limitation they may know what works you
can train them if the Drone does this it
means that so worst case you just train
them longer and and that's something
also to know in HCI we often try to do
something that is natural that is
efficient that works hundred percent of
the time but actually if you look at
airspace engineering and others it's
very hard for example to work on uh on
an airplane
because it doesn't matter you have super
bright people and you have as much time
as you need to train them
that's the beauty of it so even if your
interaction is not the most efficient
you have trained personnel and that
works with a lot of a lot of those
actors the problem is now you have
people on the other side of this so when
you have for example so this is a search
and rescue scenario you have a person
lost
if the emergency Personnel is using a
drone fantastic but how does a person
know that the Drone is coming to help
them
how does a person know that the Drone
saw them because they're very black boxy
in many ways it's like I don't know
what's going on inside it's just a drone
it's just a machine I don't have much
information and so here those are videos
we took in the Judean desert so it's
close to Jerusalem it's super super
beautiful it was a very very hot day it
was like something like 50 Celsius
like 110 my students still hate me for
it it's like but basically this journey
is coming it has a very simple interface
but he's telling this person I'm looking
for that other person have you seen them
and we created this very basic interface
and we found that just by showing this
interface with two different colors and
two different options people actually
just point to it
so that's a very natural interface here
and here the Drone keeps looking so they
didn't find the right person
but they're gonna try and find the right
person so now this person actually wants
to be found this person is lost or
injured they need help so they're happy
to see the Drone you have to realize the
other person may become aggressive and
not want to see the draw but here this
person wants to see the Drone and so
they're they're much more willing to
communicate with it
and so again we've been looking at how
could for example the Drone be uh
dropping some equipment this is not 100
working but
this is another type of research which
you're not doing right now uh but the
idea is that in these type of drones
actually can carry a lot of weight
they're quite impressive there's a lot
of uh
um noise and and wind around them and
sand being blasted but actually the idea
is that we could help for example a
search and rescue team doing triage so
the person could say if they're injured
what is their injury and pain levels we
actually talk to search and rescue teams
that would tell us these are the first
questions we would ask so first
obviously detecting if the person is
conscious which a drone is capable of
doing today there are people who work on
recognition who can do this and then if
the person is conscious if the person is
alive then they can start answering
questions so we could totally imagine a
swarm of drones going after a major
incident like an earthquake for example
going to find different people and then
the team actually gets much more
situational awareness and can do triage
and then people actually know what's
going on
because right now when you have
something happening people may see
helicopters or something they don't know
if they've been seen they don't know
when help is coming nothing is staying
with them and drones can be actually
very cheap I mean compared to a
helicopter it's crazy cheap so you could
send easily 100 drones for one
helicopter and get all this data at once
and then on the other side you can make
sense of that data without carrying the
person away yes so in these examples
where the person's interacting with it
is there also like the Drone like
speaking so yes so in this scenario we
tried speaking in a visual
so we found that visual only usually
works but speaking makes it more
personal so in a way people are more
likely to look at it when people are in
need and the problem is it's really hard
to test someone in need right you can't
really like take someone break their leg
you know leave them in the desert and
then just send it on and be like oh look
they were happy to get it uh ethics
approval IRB boards are not super open
to this type of research you have to
know and so one of the difficulty here
you can only simulate so you tell people
oh imagine you would be lost imagine you
would be in the situation your phone is
not working this this so we would give
people an idea of what the situation is
but it's never quite the same as trying
it in real life
and those are the limitations right now
of this type of research but
what we find is when there is voice
people are much more likely to like pay
attention to it so for example the
person who doesn't want help who doesn't
want the Drone doesn't
really want to help the Drone if they
realize a drone is here uh for medical
purpose for emergency purpose they're
much more willing to help it and this is
something I'm gonna talk about in a few
minutes about a different project so you
have to basically convey a minimum
amount of information to people why is
this drawn here if people just see a
drone the first instinct is what can you
guess
run usually not
hide you said not quite
throw something potentially like oh
something cool look at that over there
or something so that would be great but
people tend to be much more negative
like what we found is people see a drone
is like oh there's somebody like taking
my picture
and people are worried about privacy
again this is very culturally biased and
so we we've done actually several
research in different countries yeah for
example we found that in Asia people
were much more open to drones and much
more positive about it like we had a
study in Korea and people were like oh
the Drone could do this for me you could
do that for me and they were like so
happy and excited about it and then we
did the same study in the UK and people
were like it could be a terrorist and
we're like okay so it was really
interesting how you know based on your
own awareness of what has been happening
what you saw in the news what's going on
I guess politically within your own
country there's very big differences in
how people perceive those drones but
very often in Western culture what we
find is that people are scared people
get like oh somebody is like taking my
photos taking my videos I really don't
want to be there
and and so if you know that the Drone is
here for medical purpose of a search and
rescue people are much more willing to
share the space with it so going back to
the very first slides to coexist with it
and even to help it
and this is what I'll get to in a minute
and so this is a notion of drone
initiated communication this is actually
a paper that we're going to be
presenting at Kai in a month I guess
just about a month and basically the
idea is like we don't really have
machines initiated communication
if you think about it
no machine really comes and talks to you
even if you think about your phone
it rings so it notifies you but you have
it's your phone it's with you you know
it may ring it's a choice you've made to
have a machine that may ring to tell you
there's a communication but it doesn't
really just start talking to you the ATM
doesn't just give you cash you have to
go to ask for cash hope that there's
money on your bank account and then you
get the cash the ATM is not like hey
come on here is Cash no it doesn't
doesn't work like this
machines don't just talk to and the few
times they talk to you it's weird like
when Siri starts talking to you and you
weren't talking to it before it's like
hey I didn't talk to you go away it's
kind of like it's really weird
and so in robotics there's been a lot of
work on this machines initiating
communication and even then we're still
more used to us going to ask for help
from a robot than a robot coming to us
for for help from us
and if I go back to the road example
let's say we have an autonomous car on
the street
okay so it does his job but let's say
something fell on the street
a scooter anything
the autonomous car cannot take it away
from the street like if you were a
driver and there's a problem that's not
supposed to be there you go out of your
car you take it out you move it out to
the side and then you continue
another mess car can't do that so it's
going to need help from people around
from bystanders
but it's something we don't know how to
do yet how do you ask bystander to help
to be willing to help an autonomous
device
and so one of this aspects is how do you
even initiate this communication
and so if we look at the literature in
human human communication there are
three stages to initiating communication
the first one is you start the
communication you maintain and you end
it sounds super obvious and it is but
it's not so obvious everywhere and so
the idea is like here is how engagement
works with the person who did this work
is called Kendon this is a model that
dates back from the 90s and he says the
first thing is citing so I looked at you
now I'm looking at you you know we made
eye contact
now if I start walking towards you
chances are I'm coming towards you
and so we have all these very simple
cues in human human communication that
tells us we found each other we saw each
other the person is coming they're
coming they're coming okay at some point
they have to stop and you know they stop
too close it's kind of scary as well so
you have some spaces where you're
comfortable in spaces where you're not
but we have a very very long literature
in human human communication and how to
do this
now so it's like the sixth stages
process
citing distant salutation approach Final
Approach in close validation you have to
stop this is the main thing otherwise
the person collides into you and this is
a whole different problem and the
transition it's funny but it's actually
not it's like at some point you have to
stop when you meet a robot and the robot
doesn't know how to stop
like there is collision and it's
actually a major problem in automation
if we look at the literature on Drawn
different people have looked at
different aspects of it so
some of the work is also from my lab but
nobody looked really at the whole
process and so we wanted to see like can
we recreate that process in drones
because what happens is like the
difference between approaching Final
Approach is very minor so for example
I'm approaching you and at some point
I'm gonna just slow down a bit
and he's very very small but we're able
in human human communication to pay
attention to this but the question is
can we in robotics when drones actually
make a difference between this approach
and Final Approach so from the work
we've done we don't think we can and so
now we have created approaching as one
step and we created a four-step process
for a drone to come find a person and
interact with them
and now the idea was okay we have this
fourth stage process that theoretically
should work now can people recognize it
and how do people know so we try to use
light expressive light there's a lot of
research on how to express states of
Technology through lights so you can
just be like one you know one light
tells you it's on or off for example you
have one here I have a green light
just with this I know it's on
if it's ready probably I will assume
it's not working
so we have small assumptions of things
we already know from prior technology
the advantage of light is like it can be
seen a day can be seen in the night it's
very lightweight very easy to integrate
you can just add light onto something
that already exists
and I'm just going to show you what it
looks like and we created different
patterns
and so we built it of Prior work that
had been done on selecting states of
different types of technology and the
idea was like can I actually get people
to recognize the states the way we built
it
was very simple we just used an Arduino
board I've seen some of the projects
yesterday it's like you know how simple
it is to implement those so it's really
cool because we can take any commercial
device any commercial drone and we just
fit light on it and we had these two
configurations so the strip and the
Rings and the idea is that the Rings
kind of make it look like eyes and this
is part of the work we've been doing
over the years that we've found that
actually people
anthropomorphize robots and drones and
based on this sense of homophilization
are going to make other decision so this
is something we wanted to keep and
compare so we initially run an online
study with 156 people we showed them 26
visualizations
through video stimuli and a
questionnaire to see if they could
understand some of the states so we
actually found that some of the states
so the gray ones matched our criteria so
again I'm not gonna go too deep into
each aspect but you can find more in the
paper I can also tell you more later but
we found that specific animations were
better at representing specific States
then we looked at colors that's the
color of the LED matter and we found
that actually for searching people were
more comfortable with blue and red for
spotting with red for approaching with
orange and ready to interact with green
so we already had like some Notions
again there's a lot of research that
shows that color preferences are
cultural but we're going with like the
more generic research here so now from
this we're actually able to have a sense
of what our pupil preferences and now
the idea was to say we did this online
study it seems that there are some
colors that there are some patterns that
people will be able to understand but
now what does it look like on a drone
because the Drone is already moving and
movement is an important component we
knew from our project work that movement
is not sufficient it conveys a lot of
information you can see it's coming
towards you but you don't see it's gonna
stop
you don't necessarily know it saw you so
we wanted to combine the movement of the
drum normal behavior with the light and
to see how that worked so this is
actually a top view of like a little
garden we have on campus it looks like a
fake image but it is actually the real
image just from the top view
and the idea was to validate our
findings in this institute study so we
actually run 45 participants in three
different conditions one condition was
with 15 participants looking at a
baseline that they were only looking at
movement and then we had two conditions
with a different configuration so
Baseline stripping ring and then we had
question is an interview
so we asked people to sit down and just
to
explain to them that they were in a
search and rescue scenario that had been
injured that they were waiting for help
to come they didn't know a drone was
coming they just were waiting for help
and then they saw that drone come
so when we look at the recognition rates
on the different things so you can see
there's a major difference between the
Baseline and the strip and Rings
condition so just with movement people
were able to understand the searching
and the approaching state
but for example for the spotting and
ready to interact they were not capable
of recognizing it just from the movement
we're like about 25 percent of
recognition so it means that the light
did help they did provide strong help
now when you look just at the
recognition rates it looks like
stripping Rings is very similar but we
actually found other differences between
the two configuration
and so one of the things people were
like this is super intimidating
they were pretty worried about it it's
like this machine is looking at me and
it's like bread and so this was about
the color when for example with the
green people were like oh it means
everything is okay
so again just from the color we were
seeing some difference
and so anyway so this was a very big
piece of work in the end because we had
a whole chunk of studies uh the paper
will be presented by my student ayal it
was the end of his master's degree so I
also think that for master students to
everyone like that amount of work it's
pretty impressive but he was able to
basically find specific animations and
colors that would be what we think today
the best way of conveying this type of
information that people can actually
recognize and show comfortable about
now the next step of this work so now we
know that we can have this drone that
they can convey some information in
pretty simple way that people can
recognize they can be integrated into
teams
but actually are people willing to help
them because what we found is like I was
saying for the car before sometimes they
need help
if you send a drone for example to
deliver something to a house
it may not be clear which house it which
has number sometimes we said you know we
done it very well it's not very clear as
people we can just ask a question
you know kendrons communicate with
bystanders and so this is part of a very
large project that we conducted with the
University of Oldenburg and
suzanneable's team we worked on the
Drone side they worked on the robot side
and the idea was to say if in future
cities we have these drones and these
robots for last mile delivery and the
whole idea was around sustainability
there's a whole other aspect of how you
get funded for sustainability to do
drone research but that can be this is
about being creative and explaining why
your research is important but that's a
side note but basically the idea was to
say
throughout the kovid we've seen people
not being able to get health care
services for example or to have a
healthcare workers coming to the house
and actually putting them in danger
because the healthcare workers
themselves were more exposed and so you
could have those little drones and
robots delivering Medical Services or
medical equipment to people
and this would be super useful and again
we did other pieces of research on this
this is very acceptable people would be
very willing to work with those drones
to even have them like come through
their Windows if it can provide this
type of help
and now the idea was how do we design
them in a way that bystanders are not
going to want to like throw something at
them which was a suggestion earlier when
I see a drone but to understand this is
a drone that is coming to help someone
can I help it get to that place he needs
to go to
and so this is kind of the process so we
did it in three stages
co-designing uh the different AVS
code is adding the vehicle on the ground
so we looked first at what does it mean
to have an AV for healthcare then we
looked at more specific appearance
interaction how does it present
information and then how does it
communicate so it really had this
multiple stage process we started with a
bunch of focus groups we had different
discussions with different people to
really get uh the opportunity also for
them to design and then we validated
this with our own prototypes so I'm
gonna go fast because I won't tell you
about other things but these are
examples just from like uh co-design
workshops and what we find and it's
interesting so we did it across two
countries what you see on the top was
done in Israel and what you see at the
bottom was done in Germany
and he huge huge similarities in how
people were thinking about them so for
example people were saying oh you could
have a Red Cross
so the Red Cross is one of those uh
distinct signs that people will
recognize as Healthcare Services what's
also interesting is because in Israel we
don't have really the Red Cross as much
we have magenta vidadon which is a
different organization with different
colors still the Red Cross is like very
very strongly ingrained into our
cultures maybe also through movies and
others that this is a sign for like
medical help
there are different things about
anthropomorphism and how you should
communicate and I'm not gonna go too
deep into it but basically the idea was
this that it should have bright colors
that people should be able to really see
it hear it understand when it's like
into an emergency or non-emergency mode
so we found like specific criteria like
this that needed to be implemented
from this we've created different
prototypes and then the idea was to test
it so this is a very large drone cage
it's probably the biggest in Europe at
this point which is located at inacc
which is in the south of France in
Toulouse so I'm actually currently on
sabbatical in that lab and they have
this incredible facility to do drone
research because they have this like 10
meter by 10 meter by 15 meter drone cage
we were building one in Israel right now
but building anything in a university
takes time I don't know how long it will
take for your building to your next
building to come to life but it takes
time and effort so my drone cage is
still under construction so in the
meantime I could go there to run the
study but the idea is like we have a
tracking system that enables doing
exactly the position of the Drone
exactly the position of the person and
so we can do some really interesting
work also into knowing the micro
movements of different people I'm not
gonna get into the micro movement here
but the idea is we really went with two
main conditions one condition was that
the Drone would do its own thing so the
person had like a task about walking
into a city going to say hi to someone
bring something and then the Drone would
do their own thing and the second
scenario the Drone would ask for help
and we wanted to see how people would
react to the different scenario
and so this is what it looked like so
basically the study was like welcome
content introduction they would go
through condition one and two or two and
one and then interview in questionnaires
and so what's really interesting here so
I'm mostly gonna Focus again it's very
very large studies across like two
different Labs two different countries
it's a paper that we submitted right now
to this so we're waiting to hear but I
really want to show you the difference
between the Drone and robot does it make
a difference to have a different style
of automated vehicle because what we
found is that when we showed them when
we did the co-design workshops they
wanted the exact same things
for both types of vehicles so is it the
same
and so if we look at the noise so this
is about acceptability of robots on
three different scales
there's no difference between them so
people are pretty happy for it to be
relatively social
um I should have put you the explanation
but basically the last one is about the
the Drone being more emotional and
communicative so that was less but it's
the same between the two technologies
the guzp questionnaire is a traditional
robotics questionnaire so in terms of
likability it was pretty much the same
in terms of intelligence they found the
Drone slightly more intelligent but it
wasn't really significant and in terms
of safety they felt about the same in
terms of safety they were so pretty
positive about it feeling safe
which is always a big question because
to be really honest those Technologies
are not super safe today but people feel
safe and this is also this is a whole
different uh problem but this is
something that we found this is another
question that we looked at so what's
interesting here is we saw some major
differences between the two technologies
and here what we found is that they felt
the Drone was more informative in their
interaction
we implemented the same thing between
the two technologies we designed them to
look like each other just different
shape of devices they found the Drone to
be more useful they found it to be to
have more social presence like a lot
more social presences here and they
found it more trustworthy
now the wise yes
so I don't have all the answers
I mean we just finished this research so
now we know we know where to push the
next questions
we think that the position coming from
above gives this impression of being
more personable more relatable that when
you look at something down especially
it's something that is small that is
quite low that people tend to like look
look down upon it like literally so no
but this is really like what we found in
some of the literature as well on
robotics when you have like bigger
robots people tend to be like more and
finding them more uh trustworthy more
intelligent when they're smaller so it
might just be a size or a positioning
issue but I think it does raise some
measure questions on what does it mean
in like so it's brand new we just
finished the research but this is what
we're gonna look at next because they
were designed very very very similarly
interesting because of the cscw
literature like the old tool
Judy Olson finds these results that say
like you know the camera position in the
direction that it's looking that you
know you perceive changes the sort of
status and hierarchy so like if if your
camera is always up here so it always
looks like the person's looking down on
you it actually like they they perceive
that they have higher status and so on
whereas if they're always looking up at
you you should always Mount your camera
under your display I guess
um and it seems different here which is
interesting right if you look at these
things of like uh status and
informativeness and usefulness you'd
think that if if I have to look up to it
like I'm I'm sort of like worshiping it
it's interesting but I think there might
be some of this and so what's
interesting is I wasn't going to really
talk about it but right now we're
working on a project in Toulouse where
they designed this crazy flying platform
it's like this huge drone was like eight
different uh propellers and they put a
robotic arm on it and the idea is that
they could help a worker at altitude so
let's say somebody is like working on
the ladder and then they forgot a tool
cool then the Drone can come and bring
it to them and there's this like robotic
arm to give it to them but all the
literature I'm hand over is always
looking at objects that are taken from
down or just in front of you never from
above and never when you're in altitude
yourself or working on a roof or
something like this and so I think
there's also something really
interesting into like how do we use
those results to build the interface for
this co-working drone
thinking that people may for example
trust it too much because this is also a
problem with trust you want people to
trust your device I mean if you build a
technology you want people to trust it
but what's important is that they
trusted the right amount
if your device is not secure and we have
prior research that shows for example
that drones have propeller guards they
tend to be less seen as they are seen
less safe as when they don't
they are safer with their propeller
guards because they avoid Collision
but the look and feel of it makes it
look maybe more scary and so people find
them less safe
and so there is really a mismatch
between people's expectation of looking
at the Technologies and what is actually
happening and so how do we take this
into consideration into building future
interfaces yeah those are huge questions
yes
like if I know I'm in the city and I see
a drone I feel differently than if I'm
just walking on the road and a drone
approaches me yes so great question so
it's actually funny we're talking about
it this morning uh in one of the
one-on-one conversations so we had a
study for example a few years back
looking at how people would react to
their first encounter with a drone and
so what we did is we did a post content
study so we actually had like drones
flying into the City and Yep this is
very much what happened filming people
filming their reactions and then we
would like well not me but my students
would be running after them after to ask
for concert like can we actually use
this data like don't go don't go and so
it's
it's sort of interesting so from a study
perspective we really didn't know how to
do it because we wanted to capture this
type of interactions that we don't
usually get to capture in very like uh
lab style research but at the same time
from a IRB and ethics perspective it's
much more complex so uh we've talked to
a few people especially people who
worked like Wendy Jew when she was
working at Stanford they had all this
thing with the Ghost Rider and so I
asked them how they did it and so they
had this post content so the difficulty
is you have to throw away a lot of your
data because if people are not willing
to use it it's like let's say you get 30
40 50 people and only 20 say yes then
you only get 20 data points and there's
probably a bias from the people who said
yes that they were probably less fighted
I think in Israel privacy is less of a
concern in general like nothing is
private people don't care about privacy
like you have a lot of conversation like
someone in the room could be like taking
conversation on speaker uh while I'm
talking and nothing yeah and not even
feel this is a problem it also happened
in the movie theater and so I think
people are a lot more open to things and
don't care as much about privacy so we
actually had pretty high amount of the
people who accepted that we use the data
uh I do I think if we had done the same
research here in Europe like for example
in Germany where people are very very
concerned about privacy I think it would
have been a very different uh ratio but
again you work in the context too so
based on what you're trying to find out
to build your study like with any other
ATI experiment so sometimes you can do
things that are more controlled
sometimes less controlled but it's
actually hard to do this type of
research in something that would be like
real world
so you try to get it as close to the
real words as you can but you also want
to be you know it was the most safety uh
possible so it's not always easy and I
know the first experiments we did here
we had one experiment where people would
like get very very close to the Drone
like very close and who would be like
really scared because like okay what if
somebody injures themselves but at the
same time
like we wanted to get the data and
technically we told them not to like
walk into a drone but and so it's really
something to always consider how do you
make it as safe as possible but at the
same time you still get what you need in
terms of research
uh do you mind if I take it after I just
want to go through a few more slides and
I'm sure then we'll keep time for
question
so the next step of what we've been
looking at is could we think about small
drones that land on the body and it's
kind of going back to the work on
wearables and I actually got what is
called an ISF Grant so it's the
equivalent of the NSF career award it's
like a big grant that funds like your
your main research and the idea was to
say could I have these devices flying
onto me and away from me
but then is it like a wearable like my
phone like a tool or is it like an
extension of myself is it like having an
extra power almost in my body through
this and so we're really trying to
rethink what are the metaphors of having
this device is coming onto my body and
away from my body
and so one of the first questions was
would it even be okay for a drone to
land on a person's body that was a
preliminary work to even get funded for
the rest and actually we found it is so
what you're seeing here is if you have a
light color it means that people felt
that it would be acceptable to have a
drone land on those parts of the body so
you see that the body parts change but
for example the head is very often a
No-No except the very top of the head
which I'm not sure personal yeah would
be comfortable but you know this is like
over 159 people what's interesting is
the growing area is always a No-No no
matter what's the position of the person
but then for example the upper body is
much more uh open for people and it
really depends on the position that you
are looking at and so we were able to
actually map this and then we validated
this so this was with colleagues in
Germany so here's a student was supposed
to come to Israel and then we had
doing all the research in Germany and
not coming to visit us
so we did it on a mannequin because
again you can't really take students to
do that until you're 100 sure that it's
safe but what we did is we filmed in 360
and from this we actually had a virtual
reality study showing people what they
would experience they would still hear
the noise and they wouldn't experience
exactly the same thing but they would
still see it and have a pretty close
experience experience
and so that was a VR lab study where we
had like uh six men and six women and
basically two different drone sizes a
very small one and the bigger ones and
again a whole bunch of interview I'm not
gonna get into every level of it but
actually like people understood uh that
the Drone was landing on them we found
some aspects to be more acceptable some
aspect to be less acceptable we looked
at different Behavior different size so
again just identifying what are the
criteria that are going to matter
and so what we're doing this day is is
really rethinking and redefining what it
is to interact with automated machines
and what type of experience can we get
with those is the experience the same if
I have a drone that looks like this like
this I was like that this one is on the
ISS so it's like they're already using
this type of drones
this I mean this was built in Japan but
this is like
oh they're flying down also from Japan
this is also one thing whenever you see
very cool robotics work it's always from
Japan and you can be jealous but
basically the best like the coolest
robotics work always come from there
this this is a drone that they have in
the city it's like a mascot but they
have this drone dog we've done a lot of
research looking at how the shape of the
Drone influences what people are willing
to do with it where they're willing for
it to do Etc and it's major major effect
even though the the device may have the
exact same specification the exact same
abilities just by the way it looks it
entirely shapes the experience or
reshapes it
I just want to end on something that we
just started
but I think it's super interesting so we
looked at videos on YouTube of people
just encountering drones and so we are
starting to build the data set from this
and what we're saying is you have all
sorts of experience that people are
having so some are having fun some are
like really unhappy about it
yeah
can be very dangerous and and so the
idea is to say would we actually be able
to detect
yeah
multi-user experience
and so would we actually be able to
detect the emotional state of the person
in front of that drone for example are
we able to affect the emotional state
from the way the Drone looks or behave
and if we can if we could even just
detect if the person is going to have a
positive or negative behavior we could
change for example the position of the
Drone and if you think about coexistence
this is what we do as people every day
on you know even on the street if you
see that you're Crossing next to a
person that looks really angry you may
say okay I'm just gonna go to the other
side of the street or if the person
looks very nice you may smile at them so
it really makes a difference how we
behave towards each other what about
creating technology in the future that
can do the same and so I'm just gonna
end on this we're actually recruiting we
have a couple of new projects but one of
them is looking at this crazy dog robot
which looks very very scary and I did
not put this on on purpose because the
sound is even more scary but the idea
years like doing building Exploration
with search and rescue teams for example
and having the Drone supporting them
with um
with awareness of what's Happening uh
detection for example Etc and then the
other project that we're having is
looking at exoskeletons so this is one
of my students ayal who's very brave who
had to walk into an exoskeleton and it's
really difficult when you've never
walked into an exoskeleton but basically
we've been working with this company and
they have this amazing exoskeleton
that's helping people with spinal cord
injuries but the problem is they're very
very difficult to use like the
interfaces are nightmare you literally
have to plug in a computer in USB to
your hip exchange the speed unplug your
computer and go faster this way it's
really hard and so what we're looking at
is actually detecting upper body
movements in very small movements
because as a person is going to be
usually disabled from the the waist down
and so can we detect other body
movements parts to actually help the
exoskeleton understand the behavior of
the person and then change for example
their speed their position Etc so we're
recreating Masters PhD and post docs if
you know anyone interested let me know
and in general I think that this is just
the beginning there is a lot more that
we can do with those technologies that
they will open a lot more things for us
and I'm ready for questions I think we
still have a few minutes
so I start with you because I thought
you had a question earlier
yeah
[Music]
so that's a very good question so the
question is about the degrees of freedom
and how the movement May influence the
perception and the perception of intent
so actually I don't think is the number
of degrees of freedom so much as the
movement itself so we find that for
example people are able to understand a
lot of different intent and behaviors
for movement uh we started with this
work actually during my postdoc here and
so we found that for example if he flies
very low and slow and it stops people
understand it that's tired it's like oh
the Journey's tired maybe it's out of
battery
but then for example if it starts to fly
in a very cicaded manner then people are
like oh there's something wrong with it
so actually people are able to make a
lot of sense of uh the movement even
though we're not used to see drones
flying
when I when I really look at objects
flying I mean the only things we see
flying are airplanes and they kind of go
straight uh birds and they kind of have
their own lives we're not really we
don't have a good sense of how something
is supposed to fly at what speed but
even then people are still able to infer
intent from the movement and we can play
with this we can design with this and
this is super interesting
okay
yeah thank you for your talk for the
colors that the have you considered
colorblind people also because you know
a portion of the people in society are
colorblind and they can understand
really the color Yes okay great question
so how do we uh deal with the colors
with uh people with visual impairments
and what for example uh color blind so
we did not and and this is not the best
we did not take it into consideration in
that specific study uh you have to
realize that sadly if you look at all
the HCI literature or the HRA literature
A lot of it does not take this
population into consideration so when
you do a first study if you want to
build your work off prior work you tend
to like go for a generic population
but they are uh studies looking
specifically and people were colorblind
the thing on green and red is kind of
terrible but the problem is like it's so
ingrained into people's mind that very
often when you do an elicitation
studying ask people what color would you
use they go for these colors even though
we know those colors are not ideal so
more work is definitely needed and and
you know this is something I always find
when I come back to California whenever
you go to Europe and you cross the road
you have the little green man or you
have a little you know red one
when you go to California you have a
white person gender neutral and you have
a red person and you say oh yeah this is
like this is California and and I think
it's part of it it's really
understanding that yes colors matter not
everything is going to be adapted for
every population but when you do
research sometimes you have to do like
some choices and I don't know if that's
the best practice I'm not sure if
Michael or James if he was here would
agree but I think sometimes you have to
base your work off of what other people
have done as at least your first step
yeah
I had a question about the firefighter
cameras so when you were using the
different cameras yes were there any
changes made to like the reflectivity of
their clothing or anything like that or
it was just so we literally took we
borrowed the equipment from one of the
firefighters and so it was the same
reflective material that they have so
obviously I'm sure if we use different
uh equipment maybe it's in different
countries also a different style of hats
different type of reflex reflection
patterns that may have an effect as well
but we used the one we had available
thank you
I thought there may be one more and then
if there are other questions you can uh
come ask her after this
yes oh
um for the uh first the search and
rescue drones yeah it seems like a lot
of the interaction rely on like hand
gestures emotions have you considered
like I I'm just wondering like in cases
where because you talked about
earthquake and things like when there
are structures and when people's
movements are impeded and they aren't
able to move their upper body like very
like so so that's a great question so
right now voice recognition on a flying
drone is nearly impossible like there is
no this is this is no no this is
because if if the sound was always the
same you could filter it out the problem
is as soon as you have a bit of oil as
soon as you have a movement the sound
changes and so filtering it out is
really difficult so we actually did a
few experiments where we had like
microphones coming like down from the
Drone no it's actually there's an
underground project but it was really
interesting and from what distance do we
actually manage to hear something that
we can make sense of and it's actually
quite quite far down but if even if you
look at all the literature I'm sensing
and more like traditional robotics
nobody has really managed to crack it so
this is a huge technical challenge once
this technical challenge is like cracked
I think we have much more that we can do
with voice what we're looking at right
now is to say okay maybe maybe the Drone
does not need to fly all the time
and so if the Drone just lands then you
can start communicating with it in
different ways and then voice is a great
way to do it for sure
thank you thank you all right let's
thank our speaker
foreign